[Music]
in 2017 we discovered the first visitor
to our solar system that actually came
from another star this is really true we
discovered a really interesting type of
asteroid a rock flying through space and
it was something that we'd never seen
before we knew for a fact that this rock
could not have come from our solar
system it was going so fast that it had
enough velocity to escape the Sun's
gravity entirely in fact when it went
past the Sun in late 2017 at top speed
it was going 196 thousand miles an hour
that's by far enough velocity to
completely go away from the Sun's
gravity and go all the way out into
interstellar space now this object was
discovered by a program called
pan-starrs which is run by the
University of Hawaii it's a telescope
that looks for near-earth objects as
partially funded by NASA NASA actually
scans the sky looking for asteroids we
want to make sure the earth is never
under any threat from an asteroid that
might be coming near us we're also very
interested scientifically in where the
asteroids are and how they formed it was
named Oh mwah mwah and that's the
Hawaiian word for scout the first
arriving of many and this was the first
thing we'd ever seen from another star
so the idea of being the first being a
scout was a wonderful and poetic thing
to name this thing to give you a sense
of how unusual oh Mumma is we know that
it's a rock like an asteroid in our
solar system but it has a completely
different shape we've never seen
anything in our solar system that looks
like this it's about a quarter of a mile
long and it's actually elongated like a
cigar it's ten times as long as it is
wide and we know that it's tumbling
through space it actually tumbles and
rotates around its axis about once every
7 hours
now that means it's tumbling pretty fast
so in order to stay together and not
just fly apart it must be pretty rigid
made of of rock or even something
metallic so it's a hard object elongated
tumbling through space and incredible
speeds
there also is something mysterious that
happened as this object left our solar
system it's actually now around the
orbit of Jupiter and that has it changed
its trajectory just a tiny little bit
actually sped up a tiny little bit as it
went away from the Sun
and that wasn't expected we've seen that
sort of behavior from things like comets
that when comets have a bit of gas or
something trapped under the surface and
the Sun warms it up you can get a little
jet that comes off the comet a little
jet of gas that changes its velocity we
didn't think that Oh more more had any
of those volatile x' those gasses on it
but apparently it did as it went away
from the Sun it changes trajectory just
a little bit
it also has attracted some attention
because some people have wondered could
this be a technology could this be a
spaceship or part of a spaceship or some
people have talked about a light sail
something that actually can use stellar
winds to accelerate and move between the
stars I'm always very concerned when
somebody suggests a natural object like
Oh Momoa
might be an alien spaceship because for
one thing I think it takes away from the
incredible real facts we know about this
object and in my view of the universe
aliens are definitely not impossible
that there could be other life outside
the earth there could even be other
technologies outside the earth more
advanced races than us that's not
impossible in my view but we have no
evidence of this and this is a natural
object that you really really don't have
any reason to say it has an artificial
origin and if you're good to say that
something is an alien technology I mean
it reminds me of the quote from Carl
Sagan that I come back to over and over
again and that is extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence this
looks like a really interesting Rock
there's nothing about it that suggests
is artificial so you know I would like
us to spend some time appreciating the
mysteries of the universe for what they
are the real facts that we know we don't
need to layer aliens and Technology over
this it's already a wonderful thing to
study and I hope you learn more about it
you